الجزء الثاني من سلسله الامير هاري وزوجته
ميغان ماركل اليوم على نتفليكس كما كان
متوقعا لم يمر الجزء الاول مرور الكرام
على الرغم من ان تركيز الثنائي كان على
انتقاد الصحافه البريطانيه كان الزوجان
صيدا ثمين مره اخرى للصحف المؤيده للملكيه
يعيش الامير هاري حاليا مع اسرته في
امريكا نبذ لبروتوكولات الملكيه
وكان ميغان كانت سبيلنا جاته من حياه لم
يرد ان يعيشها ابدا في تمرضه يتم تشبيهه
عاده بعمي جدته ادوارد الثامن الذي تنازل
عن عرش اكبر امبراطوريه ليتزوج بامريكا
مطلقه الاثنين كانها تحت رحمه الصحافه
البريطانيه وان كان هذه اتخذ اجراءات
قانونيه ضد الصحف لحمايه اسرته الامير
الحزين لم يتعافى من فاجعه وفات والدته
ومنذ 20 21 يشاركوا في سلسله وثائقيه
متعدده الاجزاء تركز على الصحه العقليه مع
اوبراوند فري